[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody what's up it's
Friday and guess what we're gonna play
some Super Mario maker to 2d we just
been dancing to the soundtrack wait I'm
gonna crank it up a little bit again cuz
I'm telling you this music is poppin I
get so what's up surge I hear Lilly's
joining me again
our platformer extraordinaire did you
play a lot of the first one yeah
nice nice I mean I respect you so like I
always go back in place for Mario maker
so I'm pretty excited to play Thank You
Super Mario maker - it's out on the
switch and you know personally I've
always been pretty bad at Mario maker I
mean you go and you play like community
levels and it's like do I even know how
to jump I'm like I what is going on you
know so exactly I questioned everything
so but I always loved watching it it's
great I always think about dashi
whenever I hear this song even I'm like
- eh - eh - eh um so ya know I'm super
excited to check it out today we're
gonna be checking out the story mode
yeah and then on the Wednesday this
upcoming Wednesday next week I believe
Ben and Jake are gonna do community
Wednesday cuz we're not gonna have a
show on the 4th
fifth so on the third is gonna be
community Wednesday and they're gonna be
playing some of y'all stages prepped
yeah I know right make them suffer
that's why we all really play this game
[Laughter]
all right
let's get it poppin what is up chat
welcome back yeah some entertainment
before you even start the game yeah so
[Music]
but yeah what's up crime welcome back
row bumpiest what's up man yeah hope
you're doing well Chris Dan'l gaming
paradise Alex what's up all y'all I see
some of you posting your course IDs
already so get those ready for Wednesday
yeah Wednesday
Ben and Jake are gonna play y'all stages
and try to beat it so we're gonna check
out story mode today though so lots of
super mario make your to action right
Andy I don't know whenever I think of
Super Mario maker - she comes in my
universe he's actually pretty good - so
this dog oh my goodness
he's like cute but like he's so 2d what
why did he do this to him this dog is
ultra troll we're gonna style in on them
right now oh yeah and they's like look
that's that's the face
I'm already getting excited wait this
this toad over here is sleeping on the
job he's asleep in the house just got
destroyed
yeah no no indeed I just wanna say I did
that and is still thank you yeah this is
why my cat prison savagery
hello hard man what's up
thanks for joining us oh Allah to you as
well our reap up hope by XD alright
we're gonna do it we're gonna build
everything let's do it you gotta you
know build it from the ground up
hey back in the day you know everyone's
parents used to build their houses and
stuff themselves yeah my favorite thing
about this though is that they want meat
Mario to build a bigger and better
better cat like taskmaster yeah this guy
she's the chief and he's the taskmaster
that's not the taskmaster I know but
it's all good we'll let it slide yeah
time to build yeah we're gonna build a
little castle oh cool I'm funding this
whole thing man life hits you hard and
millionaire Mario lover Goomba lover oh
man they re spewing some fightin words
already cough up the coin downhill
battle I made a course full goombas
first one to the gold pole gets food
okay
ding OH Goomba lover me that made it
removal over wants us to kill the ghoul
yeah let's go and yeah interesting that
was a plot twist I wasn't ready for
[Laughter]
Oh okay that was like scary but then
great cousin power up Oh
Ghulam hit him with the cheese Oh big ol
Google all little goombahs like Goomba
asteroids that's definitely one of my
favorite things about mario maker in
general is that they have the option
where you can do like the retro style or
the new style get a little bit of
everything
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
queens he did say it too cause of coins
so yeah exactly one star so this curse
should be easy greetings from Bolivia
Wow greetings from San Francisco right
back at you Mauricio welcome and thanks
for joining us happy Friday
oh dude we just got all the power-ups
[Music]
[Music]
crying says check for a platform on the
second tube secret platform I know right
I want to see the secret tube the the
stream is also like donated to
I'm not going second tube okay so it's
probably one right there yeah oh thank
you for chip crying oh yeah and the ones
really like laugh at you to wholeness
heck yeah Mauricio that giant coin II
get that bad way in the little flowers -
it's like cuteness and happiness and
sunshine I'll hit him with the booty get
it Mario can't work in Mario maker -
confirms it's working on these goombas
yeah I hope you guys had a nice week
next week there's probably gonna be a
short week for you guys you know if you
work those office jobs cuz fourth of
July Independence Day July 5th but it's
kind of nice that Super Mario right it's
like okay now I got a couple extra days
seeking geek out all the new stuff cuz
there's been a lot of new games for real
I'm gonna lay down some foundation the
key to a perfect home yeah a nice
foundation
man get to work everybody like how the
toads are like yeah we're gonna help you
in theory where is the yellow one the
yellow one still asleep somewhere he's
not doing anything
iron oh boy peace dog oh it's canine
Friday at work today you guys I just
like can't control my excitement around
them okay look you put in some work
toads doing some work oh oh he's working
hard taskmaster I got three new jobs for
ya only if you're going for that an
Employee of the Month award on/off
switch research expedition hello 3d
World
okay climate okay gotcha lonely farmer
cool I know it's kind of sad now he's
just a lonely lonely farmer in a 3d
world
[Music]
he has no house what use all that Mario
didn't I was a Don
what happened farmers don't warehouse I
I don't know why this never thought
about what he might look like without a
hat gang Mario's got some skills them
climbing skills
yeah he knows clean we got a house to
build crime the music is so great this
game is hit it's too much he's so cute
[Music]
my goodness okay you know what this
needs to be the next apex Legends Mario
yes look at how he finds those walls
[Music]
[Music]
only the power of the kiddie what's the
point man we got real like detrimental
we're back Mauricio says I would like to
have a cat suit seems his nickname is is
it it's spelled mi-8 you but I'm
assuming it's pronounced like meow right
maybe kind of oh heck yeah go back we
got to get all of this all the coins I
like how he still has his clips to hook
hey meow okay super ah
you're go buzz buzz Oh Natalie's running
after even though he's like still slow
[Laughter]
all right I guess I should actually keep
going I'll be a cat eventually it's fine
Oh big block oh snap
oh okay I thought you wouldn't have
anybody jump things to do Savage oh I
see I see
you only need to cook wait are you gonna
get back on can you wall jump passage ah
[Music]
maybe only the first two levels jump
over climb up the wall and jump back
this is all theory I'm bad at this game
I should have I I jumped I jumped and
then I jumped I pressed it yes ding B
was in the way okay right watch
everything be safe cat Mario so what we
right very good
we're kitties again
[Laughter]
pretty much name we just needed the ball
run again otherwise that was great oh my
god
Luigi hey big bro you're struggling over
there googling things
what's up William we're so glad you love
our videos we love streaming play games
with you guys
yes we got this if we had just did the
wall run again I thought we should do it
like this I think two levels is fine
because as long as you hit the wall you
can make it back
[Music]
yeah get out of here we're trying to do
something okay
Oh gonna catch the wall like maybe maybe
one block of the second row so you can
have more space to jump far well you did
it the first time with the two that give
me oh oh we got cheats
we got hacks up here it's just nice to
know that they're there
[Music]
Posey's is just the bottom level just
the one ooh crime said try without it I
don't know I don't know if that's
welcome right Mario is capable of some
wild things I think that that looks good
egg show same said don't do any block so
yeah
[Music]
nice ooh we were overthinking it
good job right because it's like okay I
think most games have just trained us to
think oh we're giving this tool it
creates blocks and a prescient mask up
here but we're gonna go up their hat
size there's a cat guys I know they're
like yay you did it what can we build
with this can I build anything oh snap
we're halfway to one person of the
castle
oh boy Mario you've got some work to do
before peach gets home in the Bahamas on
vacation until you fix this you want
jobs
I get jobs
this one and then the on/off switch
known as dr. gizmo I really like the
names that they gave people lonely
armored Goomba lover dr. gizmo tamale
farmer he's still so lonely I feel so
bad do one more quests as crying I like
how they're like no one knows how it
works and the second we hit it were like
oh okay that's the classic classic what
is y'all's favorite version of Super
Mario you guys do you like the
old-school grab that run over trap his
foot would you own a chain chomp enroll
[Music]
oh there's oh wait I don't know some
people in here saying for tonight kids
wouldn't understand Mario honestly I
feel like you know it's up to us we have
a duty to educate our young and upcoming
gamers it's not their fault they were
born after the time oh oh yeah okay I
see nice there we go oh my gosh okay we
need more power
we need more star power easy easy
what's up so chill welcome back
that's good oh dang odo oh yeah the
trampolines whoops yeah see this price
easy this parts downloaded oh my god you
know what you might as well just look
wait for another stop easy easy give me
the star all right first up ya line it
up just use the way like that yes indeed
happy Friday guys weekend this here I
saw nothing I know he was talking about
might be easier to exempt up there with
a little guy tiny Mario did it
tiny Mario things
[Music]
like the tech here that's a girl
brainpower I like the little like yeah
and they're like keeping you on your
toes just in case
I feel like yes our names are lily and
Persia what's up y'all chillin on Friday
playing some Super Mario maker number
two oh snap look at that foundation that
found a nice little two-bedroom castle
with a little I don't know it's decor
why thank you Ricardo we're hoping that
you're having a great day as well this
house is gonna be rocks
that's how PG wants it any of this oh we
ain't got no Coleen's bag of coins
hey taskmaster hey some jobs another
advice talk to the chief like mom said
come talk to you well go talk to your
mom what what do you feel like I want
those 200 coins cuz we got a room to
build the birds and coins in an
underground room a while back but I
forgot where I buried them okay so we
gotta grab all 30 eccentric millionaire
Wow no wonder he just lost some coins
and it's like oh whatever whatever this
one was a four story difficulty though
well alright
can't wait okay we got five star talent
on the six
my dude Bob Jones says you have to build
the middle room first so we'll see I
already mess up now we didn't select
that a room because our building in
Green had no money like some male we're
gonna go to the bank and they have those
tubes and the drive-thru okay everybody
wants to see angry Sun next a well-run
angry Sun after this which I get these
cones you are we got a house to build I
[Music]
go they go through the tubes also I
wanna so they don't give you any was I
gonna say they don't give you any way to
do stuff or like hallelujah oh yes oh
you're just like Baby Mario the whole
time bit Mario cuz you only get this
once
yeah yeah I think you can get through a
few of these without it
I like how forgetful they are they're
like oh my god I hate you coming after
you it's okay I remember you and yeah
we've got seven of 30 Wow he came back
he was like psyche coming back those
tubes
I was I was being too boy
oh and in Luigi the old big bro I do
like that they give you especially for
kids I like that was my mistake you're
in the groove yeah yeah like yeah I can
grab this and get out I don't know I'm
gonna double oh seven
yeah easy I mean the time raised a
little shorter in this stage but it is
it's not too bad
all right we out get out of the way at
the door Goomba okay what's up it's like
it feels like pac-man oh wait no what I
was shook for a moment he's coming back
I think the goombas run off of the stage
but the turtles I like now great success
boom swing of rooms down a little Mario
Robert oh yeah this is when we might
need a now we're good we're good we're
good
very good let them with Metal Gear
Mario's this is Mario guidance they're
throwing evil ninja stars at us and I
love I love that the pink ones ninja
star has a bow on it
just gonna throw that out there that is
okay okay now we're good we're safe yeah
cuz it's the last room
just going to run through it uh-huh kill
is any of them make it easier for us
yeah I like how they can fly but they
feel like I want to use the tube oh yeah
what's up says I've got great you got a
battle Bowser or something all right we
got all these this millionaires coin we
hitting second so be taller Shaivism
blocks down this time view away anybody
[Music]
go for it do it oh yeah back to what we
said earlier
Mario can do everything just when you're
like I don't know if you can make this
yeah like a booth though okay
hi I've got money crime said Mario is
for sure an Italian mobster
do you like the 3ds or the Wii U says
maddox I think they're both good I mean
I have more games on my 3ds then on the
Wii U but I like the weeds and I have
more games on my 3ds too but I don't
know I just
the we just kind of I don't know I'd
like to cuz it's in tune and like Super
Mario maker there's just some fun games
there that I think didn't get some
recognition and now they're coming to
the zoo but I feel like I never played
my 3ds with the 3d on yeah I just
immediately turn it off never turn it on
again oh man get to work peach is about
to be so happy with this house like
I love her so much the things that Mario
does for this woman for sure let's go
complete God he's got so many jobs
I like how you know it's a video game
but they're like hitting us with some
real-life reality they're like Oh your
house got destroyed how we can rebuild
it but where's the money
insurance not gonna come to that oh boy
darn great angry son let's do this
that's right
all right angry under the angry son
amateur meteorologist says today in the
desert expect clear sighs all day with
the chance of solar flares whoa
by the way there's an angry son good
luck
he's so hype till he's like angry Sun
and solar flares tune hey Sullivan this
game does have a story mode we're
actually playing it right now and on
this upcoming Wednesday we're gonna be
oh snap he looks like he's about to
traitors on their wings falling off is
like anything stop it easy son - soon I
like the Sun I think it changed his look
anyway whoops guess he's angry yeah if
you've owned a Wii you give a shout-out
to the Wii U they're all they also just
received an update oh snap I just
received an update
[Music]
I like that even though they have all
these other platforms and stuff now
there's be still put updates and you
know take care of their other platforms
too right oh he was like I'm out of here
fly how do we fly guys which button is
it I thought it was one of the triggers
by could people thought so too I think
it's one of those just press them all I
made a huge mistake guys all right we're
back throwback I was like do you got the
skills it's fine we made it like I've
seen this before yeah I prefer Mario to
be a cat more than fly but you know
those moments where you like clay
there's so many Mario games right and
then like you play and then you're like
how do I do this how do I like remind me
how to do this again yeah cuz every
Mario game they add something new or
they add like a new little future and
they're like we yeah how to do it
because and you do it again and really
and then someone says oh just shake the
control and you're like
[Music]
[Laughter]
but yeah
mr. ma'am or mr. man the fourth you're
new here welcome the Haunted Manor or
swinging claw rope horse shoe stopper
the keymaster
you know I'm greedy I'm with the gold
when it comes to games and they're like
get the coins I'm like all right let's
get these coins all right let's do that
let's do - I'll pay anyone who makes it
to the end link interest annual after
trophy saves the universe I don't
believe any ones that says they have a
special ending if you collect everything
oh oh boy
oh man this is like one of my favorite
cowboy
um soundtracks though I just like it
both the key do I need to take one of
these I think oh man it's like which one
I think I need the the POW or the peace
so which one should I grab what do you
feel like let's try the PAL let's try a
panel
don't look at me don't don't follow me
oh oh it's the power oops I forgot I
mean the play like this if you switch oh
it's still here though don't look at me
close your eyes when you're looking at
me oh okay door gotcha
way is there anything to the left or
that's just where you ran in from the
tube up here what is this what are you
he's a lazy ghost he doesn't feel like
flying around so he just stays in the
floor whoa I can't kill him can i okay
you need the the spring oh that's right
get out of here spring it up spring a
spring
don't know get it out
don't mind your business ghosts mr.
ghosties okay so I got this one
oh okay these guys throw it down jump on
it give you one swift motion I know
nothing I'm just giving us these flag
tips for no reason I don't know if it's
gonna work I'm not a soccer player I'm
Mario I was trying to get your pain gone
guys if you do I know who paying is go
bless yourself today and watch some of
his videos it's Mario maker on the next
level I'm sure he's already gonna be
doing some craziness with this game oh
snap
Oh Mario said he loves Mario maker too
so much he's gonna make a level just for
us at GameSpot thank you this coming
Wednesday I think you just hold down No
yeah yeah there you go I know lazy go
[Music]
[Music]
set it down and then immediately jump
yeah I believe in you oh man don't look
at me but yeah guys this Wednesday Ben
and Jake are going to play your levels
that you make so start making those
levels now and I mean I don't know how
they're gonna collect codes but I would
have seemed you can leave your code in
the comment section of this video once
it is up on our YouTube channel and the
live stream portion of it is over so
yeah put those codes in the comments all
so that we can torture Ben and Jake
hello Willie we are doing great
playing some Mario maker all right let's
do it
come here ghosty thanks crying ghosty
mr. ghosty oh I love you guys oh yeah
see they're just psyching us out I'm not
sorry okay Aisha please don't like as
far to the right so that wouldn't go
start digging it
[Music]
it's like if I'm moving I have to just
stop moving nope
[Laughter]
you got this there we go yeah it
definitely has to be on the second
flower might feel like no this is Mario
we can't forget do everything okay so
that one's a lot faster okay bring it on
bring it on all right mr. man said I
wonder if there's a hidden block
somewhere hmm
is that I don't know I know that's
something on made on made levels people
do that all the time but okay yeah maybe
there's a block here somewhere maybe in
the middle if I stop jumping even yeah
you're gone goner yes okay okay man why
keymaster year on that one yeah I
believe sometimes you got this oh right
oh my we need this key it's right there
I'm looking at it could do it Willie
says he wants this game well oh you know
what yeah it can't go on the second
platform there's no way it's gonna be
too far away to make it Mario trying to
live tiny dreams right make it up okay
he got to see this easy easy
I think I had much of much higher boost
when I was when I first launched and
then I starts the rage is incoming yeah
yeah bully says he wants his game well
this game came out today officially so
check it out yeah welcome back to this
one let the salt simmer down a little
bit on the third oh that's right he's
got a boost e right he's got a boost
wait was that in this version no that's
the other thing we have to remember it
wing which version was that
[Music]
was easy oh okay this is these rude
ghosts in the way no nice oh I also you
know what I just realized
I need the jump pad I need to jump ease
- the jumpies - yeah
no we're coming back for it for the
keymaster he didn't get the best of us
we're just taking a break from that room
for a second yeah totally because if not
this patrollers going flying we'll see
we'll see a little fire like right here
by the mushroom yeah okay yeah yeah like
what's what's above there
what is this just an empty room it's if
there's nothing in the second circle
another has to be there has to be
promises broken dreams yeah we can baby
down slowly opening oh oh nice they say
it looks like get out of here peace out
peace you guys I love I think being a
little ninja Rendon don't look at me
[Music]
don't you don't you know don't you dare
look at me
all right Oh oh yeah get one of those
bad boys real quick I'm tall now I'm
told Mario all right one more door in
the books oh okay that's silly man I
wonder where this fifth key is that
because that door is right there where
you get every single key except for the
one that I'm missing okay
[Music]
I think there was one all the way to the
left you didn't check out yet well it's
gotten another springy thingy oh don't
tell me they're gonna do that oh wait
put the spring on that didn't jump on it
and you're gonna get super jump status
yeah okay oh you can make it there's
platform it's like trampoline you're a
kid they get peak bounce how do you just
stand on it until the spring is at its
highest buy-in I don't know I feel silly
oh okay it goes up a little higher every
time so it's like you jump and then it
comes up and then jump again
[Music]
yeah yeah morning everyone what are you
doing but I mean let's be real
I only know very few people who are
actually God like a platformers and
Mario me oh yeah yeah there spraying
shebang
let's go 94 seconds we've got this
easy-peasy we're don't oh no the music
[Music]
[Music]
yeah there we go oh this is this getting
oh we got this come on Mario it's not
even a even Mario this time
it's so efficient it's like the platform
is right there not timing it right all
right it's it's the music the music is
putting on this pressure all right
we should start oh that was it we're
just be praised and dude it's it's
because I have to hit it when it's gotta
hit it just right
[Music]
no girl might have to restart this bad
boy to 2084 years okay we're gonna do
the pro speed run level after this
attempt yeah
real YouTube users like goodness
gracious I'm saying
yeah don't watch 50 seconds can we build
it we started restart this bad boy right
now over okay so agent - we gotta talk
I know right agent - no big little
Braille wants to help bro what were like
amateur hour
all right let's do this Oh hold on to
the keys until the end next time you can
hold more than one so instead of going
to the door every time got to make use
of our 500 seconds
yeah all right we're gonna do this again
Thank You Omari says stay cool and think
and you will make it and when the
inspirational words of Omar yay
[Music]
jump once it's up there where it's like
it has to think I'm doing it too yeah
let's watch the pattern in the springs
without jumping for a few seconds to see
which about is this one it's the second
okay
watch my version oh god no yes you do
look at me we did it once already you
know it's possible yeah but it actually
was I didn't even think about it it's
the key
oh yeah okay let's go get it that's the
key I quit 84 years later five hours
late there no yep yeah knock out these
ones these ones were the easier ones
I think this yeah it's um it's like
right here right yeah next to the shrews
oh wait okay no your kid if you do baby
bounces oh snap well he got his hands on
troffer that games really fun i 100% of
it and it was great see how we haven't
gone into this room yet oh boy
I know what I need yes we need the piece
which also there is probably a true
ending when if you grab all the keys yes
I'm very curious but I also don't know I
have no patience for this level oh boy
oh the keys in one of these blocks whoa
okay so we know it's that one it's in
the one on the right okay so I'll be
back so I think when you turn on piece
which goes away and then hit the square
in the middle from underneath I'm tiny
so I have two bondage in hiding I have
to be tiny guy boom boom okay
right let him make you tiny yeah great
don't don't like Adams anymore boom
alright that that was some great
thinking right there had to take the hit
intentionally all right go get our
mushroom real quick wait are we gonna go
for that 15 no forget that key let's get
out of his level I am NOT agent two why
is music going so fast okay freaking me
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no that's the true ending right there
so you can only get okay so the true
ending is like five more oh my goodness
that's cool
that is cool I didn't do it I know we
want to show off more the story about
you guys you can we can always go back
later and replay these levels yeah I did
it
yeah exactly we're gonna post the clip
later are you doing up doing all of it
alright so a shoe stopper actually I
kind of went through the mystery of the
Haunted Manor yeah we might definitely
need Little Joe and agent one Oh No the
true rival can someone come and get me
out of here
okay ooh I haven't had a big red in a
long time good soda oh I thought you
were nope that is that they have gum -
yeah yeah the soda is kind of teasing
had big red in a long day and I think
about it it's a southern thing and I
think because I was originally born in
Texas and there was like this big this
big big red factory smash those blacks
no no no no left
which will oh these go Brown them oh
wait what Kenny let's slide
[Music]
mr. man says morning there are tons of
bad puns to come in the level names I
love bad puns that's like my favorite
thing of all universe ready for it I
think my brain definitely feels like
tomatoes for sure kinda cute
well whose feet are invincible as a
weapon I love me some Yoshi all at home
my wife is called Yoshi's Island see you
creeping on us but--
are you guys excited for God Eater 3 for
in as soon by any chance OSHA map I mean
I never really played God either but I
know it's definitely been super popular
so I'm mainly excited that a lot of game
they're just coming to the switch which
is awesome huh yo she's the best what's
up Nikki and Misha welcome yeah yeah
easy
yo she's so cute I can't we have
real-life Yoshi's with his little shoes
on I'm saying Oh what was that
Oh haunted Manor right so we've entered
the matrix oh that was the last one oh
and then we get okay so I see what's -
we have to go through the door and Boo
just once hug well cry a me oh really I
said he also has the switch version of
Katamari I'd like that game it's really
fun
you just roll around no carries in the
world
you gotta jump off of them right boo is
cuter than Yoshi that is some fighting
words right there I don't know if I've
seen anything cuter than Yoshi that
beepings honoree Yoshi is destined to be
tossed off an edge it's the most
heartbreaking thing whenever I've played
a mario and I had to abandon Yoshi to
like a pit or something to get somewhere
like that it's just so cruel it's so
cruel sorry everybody so close we got
this right those a weird state ruses
booze a pervert right he's always
creeping on us and we turn around and
then he closes his eyes as we can see
him baby Mario is very cute
he's only annoying if you lose him I
kind of feel like we should that dork
right there is just gonna
I just realized that Yoshi can sprint oh
yeah
best comment just said that to make sure
to hold sprint the whole time because
he's a no-show there's another switch
[Music]
[Music]
it's like when you're trying to go
somewhere and someone shuts the door in
your face patroller II and we can see
what's behind that door
oh the 30 coins cuz we saw the other
door like we got built this house for
peach we gotta get those come you know
what peach is ungrateful she's a little
bit oh we're running out of time again
baby peach is you know forget those
coins through out of here it puts the
pressure on needed
it's got to be hidden platforms here no
I have to go through the door Oh oh nice
fool I was I was about to leave you oh
shoot
never sorry every game needs a troll why
is mario so like Hawaii no she makes a
boy for reals
man we're raking in the dough now all
right go work meanwhile the chief what
is she doing she's looking cute so she
stopped her shoes stopper I like it the
shoe goombahs are too much and the kicks
they're rocking are useful they let you
walk over spike traps okay
missed opportunity to call them Zumba's
just saying celebrity deejay that's
great deej now we know I eschew stopper
[Music]
hi egoriy welcome to the stream happy
Friday
happy Friday dating Aaron says Mario's
forever in the friend zone
like how the Goomba shoe is like one
shoe it's not like a parish it's one
singular shoes those sweet cakes those
air Mario's you guys get those new air
Mario's oops he read the read the jump
[Music]
the greed the greediness shoe buzz buzz
[Music]
gasps boot
[Music]
he does look pretty cozy in that boot
[Music]
Mario with the fresh kicks is fast too
oh all that we out we out of here I
think you needed the little boot to hop
in there Paulo's do so keep your boot on
all over that boot a little oh we have
little stilettos noise go back and get
these coins for our girl teach we're
friends own but it's fine that doesn't
mean we don't have to yeah success
applause Cheers
[Music]
if it wasn't one thing it was another
when it rains it pours oh my goodness no
[Music]
sorry cap ate twice to ground down maybe
not in the boot boots are made for
walking okay shoutouts the Hanny not
paid twice to our town with the stiletto
fierce yes you know we got a channel
young tyra banks and get our stomp on
that's how you really runway walk in
these streets okay pound get you in
ground pound oh only working shoot we're
too high fashion for that here oh wait
you might need the the shoe to crash
shoe those boxing in those balloons Oh
flying boots now these are really the
air Mario's right here the green can get
the best of us this time
[Music]
the heels Doosan Medellin oh we're still
in the boot don't rush take your time
I'm the flying boot did sound like a
little fart when I was like oh snap the
main hall first for God peaches so lucky
he's building her multiflora multi-room
castle from scratch thank you here's a
cake right
it's definitely cake she's so annoying
guys just standing there watching
everything out West Hall or East Hall
what do you feel like or the we stall
can't do that that way yeah let's do
East you sure about that right I mean
you see there east or west there's no
north or south so great I can do both oh
because we are ballin Mario is ballin
all the money he made out of his air
Mario's is funding this house can I
build more stuff while she crimes really
trying to lay on the puns now
all right we had enough money we didn't
both see the greed paid off we multitask
we got all the towed oh yeah the stream
is a little bit ahead of the chat so if
we are responding to your questions late
that is why it's okay we still reading
we're still paying attention yes peach
needs to help out you're right we need
her eye of design and tunnel to the Dark
Side of the Moon without jumping off the
ground and landing the gamemaster yeah
take care out there even toad was like
oh man I don't know about that there's
one in splatoon like the octo expansion
where you only have like a limited
amount of ink that you need to use Oh me
and if you don't okay here we go
reach the goal without landing oh boy
all right okay he goes back under okay
okay so far so good kind of easy just
slow I can't jump and of course we're
gonna get these coins
oh okay
okay yeah it didn't count I was landing
after job nice they looks so satisfying
though that's so so much
yeah like I could just watch that for a
while let's think about this I can't I
can't jump so I have to go down and
around wha-what restart what are you
supposed to do you didn't jump you just
ran off of a Ledge just that that
doesn't count that that I mean like Oh
without landing after leaving the ground
he's not after jumping so it worked last
time because you were still on the
platform no tricks
there's the game master I don't think we
can go that way try not to go into that
one I guess was that the only one cruel
[Music]
yeah still we're not getting this oh
you're gonna die I see you bud it's like
you're not gonna die but you're gonna
fail the condition I think that the like
employees or whoever was making the game
they're like we need you to come up with
some like really fun names oh yeah
definitely like I Loki wish I got that
job because I would have been all over
it
mainly farmers guys I planted some trees
[Music]
so I can't get help by this okay so we
go right crime he was like the greed
finally paid off it did hello people of
the interest rate equip and light spider
rampant monkey Bob Jones all y'all
welcome okay so I think I needed those
things
oh so let them move cuz I think once
they move over it all
wow they're so nice I was like what is
it
[Music]
[Music]
what oh we forgot gamemaster why no I
was so focused on tell we were feeling
good with the booster giving him a stern
talking dude okay master really fitness
to the test it's like you can't forget
for a second no you can't
[Music]
all right God peaches lucky going
through all of this okay because if this
was Mario's choice he would not be
building this whole castle I bet you it
would have been a studio apartment that
sucked in coins the build
yeah yeah keep your feet moving I have
one life left
wah make it count
oh my god I am drinking coffee okay
thank you very much don't touch you know
it's it's still them oh no it's not it's
technically the afternoon here now it's
1216 which means they have 15 minutes
left to get this stage completed which I
believe looks like it's good
hello atomic still welcome hope you guys
have been enjoying the stream so far
we're playing some of the story mode but
this upcoming Wednesday Ben and Jake are
gonna be playing your levels so make
those levels leave the code in the
comment of this video and then I'll
scoop them up for you guys so should be
really fun and exciting okay wait yeah
okay great oh he picked you up you have
to walk onto the
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
too bad too bad oh my goodness I just
took off my headphones and everything
guys you know we weren't expecting it to
work itself out on its own it's a
natural reaction to just jump oh that
was pretty good game master that
reaction was it was a jump scare we're
here every week gonna get my composure
back you know I have to pay my respects
as well kiss whew that was a real one
that was a real amun right there all
right just remove your hand from the
jump button completely
alright alright now we're gonna let
homie do his thing
nice and easy
oh my gosh yeah yeah oh my goodness okay
the definite you have to be careful not
to let it bump you it has to be
perfectly still alright we out oh my god
what okay
what in the so you're gonna have to bait
food to come over and be above you
somehow that's the only thing I can
think of you above you
yeah like go close to him and then turn
and slowly walk him over to the edge and
then in theory he'll stay above you I
don't know he might not but that's the
only conclusion I can come up with with
this little dip here yeah yeah alright
go easy easy we out this loan is some
view like riding up the hill while
you're looking at you okay alright got
this oh man they're really trying to get
you I feel tested
like do we even want to go that way yeah
I can't it's jumpsuit yeah yeah no not
leave it
whoo all the bait is the real like one
all these coins look at these delicious
Colleen we don't want to know okay
Wyatt how are you supposed to hit the
p-switch without jumpy can you oh oh
look there's a there's a block to the
left so maybe pick it up and let let
block man Wow there we go oh my god
these things make you bounce oh okay I
made it I do not know if oh you have to
go in there you have to go in the tube
[Music]
we're not no wait oh my goodness
hold up oh boo boo is on is underneath
the thing
come here boo all right
okay guys sweet walk forward yeah yeah I
like this teamwork boo oh gosh I like
the green I like the game I'm not even
doing high five did it did it that is
actually really fun game master is
savage in this level Oh Mari you're
right jump on behind that see Bonnie
that's actually fun one that was fun yes
we have time for the desert sands
[Music]
ambush oh yeah you know for the name
alone I feel like Dark Side of the Moon
needs to be our final one I think it
also shows exactly everything we've seen
the birds
gravity's weird
this one will be fun got some classic
classic Mario Jamin out of the music and
jump again oh yeah yeah exactly
oh snap Aaron says he's loving it he's
gonna be picking it up thank you ladies
well you are welcome and
we appreciate you joining us and
watching us play we've been having a
really great time
I love songs a banger it's okay it's
okay we had the shrooms nice it's
working on them I like the little stars
can I can't I can't go down there got to
go back to the right side up
[Music]
[Laughter]
attention to this guy we're trying to
figure it out mischievous mole no oh
snap Iron Maiden's grabbing his game to
nothing I'm talking bellow you and
stress you out all at the same time
[Music]
booty bump they got the beat they got
stomp on catch these air Mario's know
you're the best gray wolf you all of you
at home don't forget it we love you guys
not this time shell
[Music]
I will grab this money your whole
equilibrium there just off now game
master man that was rough all right oh
he got Jukes he baited is it possible to
play co-op uh uh I'm not sure
[Music]
someone needs to sire freestylin some
Mario oh yeah there is a local co-op in
Super Mario make it two at least that's
what beat in their net is telling me
co-op building mode is what it is yeah
oh yeah
right on time oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
success we done built some things
reaches house is underway we almost have
the whole first floor done but that is
gonna wrap it up for the stream today it
was fun I got an awesome time it's great
oh crank rhyme says you can co-op levels
as well so you know we just wanted to
show off some of the story mode for you
guys and you
you know maybe Ben and Jake might check
out co-op mode on Wednesday but I know
for sure they're gonna be taking your
codes and your levels and giving them a
try so so come up with some really fun
stuff yes push them to the limit so that
we can all laugh at their expense
yeah exactly so once this video is up on
our YouTube just leave those codes in
Commons so that Ben and Jake can scoop
them up and try them out on Wednesday so
happy Friday you guys have a great
weekend and we will see you guys next